et Eric berger d'avoir été avec nous on
va parler de cette mobilisation que vous
soutenez Nicolas meilleur signal est-ce
que vous pensez que cette journée peut
faire le gouvernement je
l'espère parce que on va d'abord qu'il y
a sans parler du fond un problème de
méthode c'est quand même assez rare que
tous les syndicats soient unanimement
opposés ça fait université syndicale
d'habitude et les positions différentes
et là ce qu'on voit quand même c'est
qu'il y a uneanimité c'est qu'il y a un
souci il y a un souci de méthode et en
plus toutes les études d'opinion
montrent qu'il y a une majorité de
Français qui sont aussi opposés à la à
la réforme donc il y a vraiment un sujet
de méthode de concertation il y a un
problème de méthode Gérard Longuet dans
la manière dont le gouvernement a amené
cette réforme des retraites depuis 2017
le président de la République a été
candidat sur un changement de système
auquel il a renoncé
fraude de l'avoir approfondie et parce
qu'en réalité ce système ne pouvait pas
ignorer la réalité démographique
française qu'il y a de plus en plus de
retraités et par rapport à cela de moins
en moins de cotisants donc on est obligé
de trouver une solution
le président de la République pendant sa
campagne il faut le rappeler avait dit
65 ans ce qui nous avait surpris plutôt
encouragé d'ailleurs
et puis il reprend cette avec Madame
borne cette mesure je crois qu'il y a
des il y a des choses à débattre je
partage pas la vie de Monsieur le
meilleur Rossignol je crois que
maintenant il faut le faire rien ne
désagréable dans cette affaire mais
c'est le rien n'est agréable dans cette
affaire mais si le prix à payer pour
avoir une démographie
différente on va parler du fond et de la
nécessité de cette réforme mais est-ce
que vous vous redoutez que le
gouvernement ne recule si la
mobilisation est trop forte
je ne vois pas pourquoi il reculerait il
a il a une légitimité présidentielle une
légitimité parlementaire je comprends
très bien que les gens manifestent et
payent aucun enthousiasme à travailler
plus enfin sauf certains mais ce qui est
mon cas j'adore travailler mais il faut
la faire il faut la faire si on veut les
payer avant de parler du fond je
voudrais juste répondre sur le point qui
concerne la légitimité politique
j'entends effectivement que c'était dans
le programme de Monsieur Macron c'est
tout à fait juste mais je rappelle quand
même que nous sommes des millions dont
je fais partie à avoir voté pour
Emmanuel Macron au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle pas pour qu'il
passe à 65 ou 64 ans mais pour empêcher
la haine pour empêcher Madame Le Pen et
je pense il l'avait dit d'ailleurs le
soir de son élection qu'il devrait en
tenir compte et la manifestement et puis
ensuite on va parler du fond
manifestement il n'en tient pas compte
alors c'est vrai ce que vous dites moi
j'ai voté Macron deuxième tour parce que
je ne voulais pas voter pour Marine Le
Pen dans le programme est parfaitement
décousu
et il y a un vrai problème en France
c'est le contrat du deuxième tour il
n'est jamais organisé et donc jamais
respecté c'était vrai d'ailleurs avec
Chirac en 2002 ça a été assez vrai avec
le
Macron 2017 et nous avons un vrai
problème institutionnel le gagnant prend
tout sauf que le gagnant il a 25 % des
voix en réalité complètement d'accord
sur le fond de cette réforme générale
Longuet 17 réforme est nécessaire elle
n'est pas nécessaire pour vous cette
réforme Nicolas meilleur Rossignol il y
a plusieurs façons de faire une réforme
et il faut pas confondre réformes et
régression le point de départ qui a
exposé monsieur Longuet on peut le
partager il y a plus de personnes étant
mieux d'ailleurs qui sont plus âgés
d'ailleurs c'est d'abord un sujet de
société parce que là on parle tout de
suite d'argent c'est important bien
entendu enfin le vrai sujet c'est la
place des personnes de plus de 60 ans
dans notre société mais je passe et
effectivement c'est un peu un problème
de combien de personnes cotisent pour
alors il y a plusieurs facteurs
là-dedans parce qu'il y a d'abord le
facteur de productivité on n'est pas
productif aujourd'hui comme hier et puis
dans le volume de personnes si je peux
me permettre de m'exprimer ainsi qui
cotise justement on sait qu'en France
par exemple sur les plus de 60 ans
seulement 1 sur 3 travail si vous
augmentez le nombre de personnes qui
travaillent après 60 ans vous augmentez
le nombre de cotisants on peut aussi
parler des jeunes les jeunes en France
rentrent sur le marché
les jeunes qui rentrent sur le marché du
travail en général ont des difficultés à
entrer sur le marché de travail si vous
en avez plus plutôt sur le marché de
travail vous avez plus de cotisants
aussi les femmes les femmes ont un
salaire en moyenne de 22% environ
inférieur à celui des hommes et 40% pour
la retraite quand même si vous arrivez à
réduire cette inégalité salariale qui
est scandaleuse bon et bien vous avez
augmenté mécaniquement les cotisations
donc vous voyez quand même qu'il y a
plusieurs pistes et puis ensuite vous
avez la question du financement parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout le financement de
cette retraite est portée sur qui sur
les travailleurs mais il pourrait y
avoir d'autres pistes de financement le
patrimoine et les cotisations patronales
il y a la fiscalité des entreprises il y
a des choix fiscaux si on supprime la
CVAE c'est un choix si on supprime l'ISF
c'est un choix je ne dis pas qu'ils sont
pas légitimes c'est un débat politique
mais ce sont pas les miens et tout ce
que j'essaye de dire c'est que on
pourrait trouver d'autres pistes pour
une justice sur cette réforme il y avait
pas d'autres moyens que de repousser
l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans Monsieur
Meyer parfaitement raison il faut
améliorer l'entrée dans la vie
professionnelle et le développement de
l'apprentissage je vous rappelle que les
apprentis sont des salariés qui cotisent
est une bonne chose et il faut en effet
que les gens travaillent jusqu'à le plus
longtemps possible et qu'on garde des
gens qui sont en pleine forme
intellectuelle et physique les garder en
activité ce sont des avantages mais il y
a une réalité forte c'est que
tendanciellement on vivra plus longtemps
ce qui est une bonne chose et on aura
besoin de faire des études donc il y
aura un peu moins de codes les cotisants
des marrons plus tard et pour l'instant
on ne sait pas financer les retraites
dans les 20 ans à venir j'ajoute que
tous les autres pays d'Europe sont
au-delà de 64 ans dans commence majorité
avec une différence c'est qu'ils ont en
général deux systèmes répartition et
capitalisation et c'est la
capitalisation qui manque en France il
faudrait un mélange des deux systèmes
pour votre
régime de capitalisation paradoxalement
sont les fonctionnaires qui ont
bénéficient
avec un système complémentaire je crois
qu'il faudrait de plus généreux
nous nous sommes très attachés au
système par répartition parce que c'est
une forme de solidarité qui est au coeur
de notre République mais peut-être pour
reprendre un peu de capitalisation pour
vous il faut pas introduire un peu de
capitaine je pense que le point clé
c'est quand même d'abord la répartition
ce qu'on sait en revanche c'est que pour
quelqu'un qui a bien gagné sa vie tant
mieux pour lui en fin de carrière
souvent il va placer une partie de son
patrimoine pour se faire une un
complément de retraite mais ça ça n'est
pas accessible pour quelqu'un qui a des
revenus modestes et vous voyez le type
d'inégalité qui renforce l'injustice de
faire payer toute la retraite sur les
travailleurs qui ne peuvent pas se
permettre de voir ce système système de
capitalisation mais je voulais revenir
sur deux points juste pour donner un
chiffre je vous ai dit 1 sur 3 des plus
de 60 ans de travail donc 30% 33%, c'est
un des scores les plus faibles de tous
les pays de l'Union européenne si on
passait à
45%, on financerait le déficit annoncé
par le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites donc vous voyez que c'est pas
non plus des chiffres si terrible que ça
alors c'est 30 à 45 c'est pas évident
mais les mesures qui sont proposées dans
le projet de Madame borne ce sont des
mesurettes c'est un index bon on va dire
on va vous montrer du doigt si c'est pas
suffi maintenant c'est c'est
probablement pas suffisant vous voyez ce
que je veux dire et puis il y a aussi un
autre point qui n'est probablement pas
pris en compte aujourd'hui c'est que en
fait plus notre société évolue plus on
voit des inégalités sur la pénibilité
des métiers y compris d'ailleurs des
pénibilités qui sont pas prises en
compte moi je suis toujours cet exemple
pourquoi vous croyez que plus personne
ne veut travailler à l'hôpital public
mais parce qu'il y a des facteurs de
pénibilité d'ailleurs souvent pour les
femmes aide-soignante par exemple port
de personnes qui sont en situation de
détresse il y a des problématiques de
santé physique et mentale et on sait
très bien que à 60 ans ou 65 ans tout le
monde n'arrive pas en même état état de
santé physique état de santé mentale si
vous avez bossé toute votre vie dans un
bureau en gagnant bien votre vie tant
mieux pour vous bon vous n'êtes pas dans
un même état si vous avez bosser sur les
chantiers portuaires à Rouen
pour vous Nicolas meilleur signal après
on va parler du nucléaire au PS on
entend certains qui disent il faut
maintenir la retraite à 62 ans et
d'autres comme Olivier fort qui disent
il faut revenir à la retraite à 60 ans
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a écrit dans
l'accord de la nuque qui a signé le
Parti socialiste comment vous pouvez
vous faire entendre avec autant de
divergences
je vais pas faire de langue de bois je
pense qu'effectivement c'est un problème
du Parti socialiste aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui c'est la journée la
mobilisation donc je dois quand même
dire la première chose aujourd'hui c'est
l'opposition à une réforme qui est une
injustice et une régression après je
vais pas faire de langue de bois
aujourd'hui entre la position qui a été
votée au moment de la loi Touran y
compris par Monsieur fort la position
dans le cadre de la cordelanup 60 ans 40
nut la position de la candidate Anne
Hidalgo et la position personnelle de
l'effort ça fait 4 positions différentes
ça fait beaucoup je vais pas vous dire
que ces quatre mariages un enterrement
mais enfin ça fait beaucoup donc ça va
pas et effectivement c'est pas normal
qu'un grand parti d'ailleurs tous les
grands partis de responsabilité à gauche
et à droite devrait avoir une façon de
s'opposer et une façon de
je l'ai dit d'une formule pour battre la
droite vous pouvez pas juste battre le
pavé quoi
[Musique]